Maybe somewhat surprisingly, the left model that of Ptolemy has so many knobs to turn
that it allows more flexible calibration and that it even allows
more accurate prediction of the apparent motion.
Footnote--in a modern perspective, this stack of epicycles actually is a Fourier series.
Historically, it turned out that circles around the sun are not good enough.
Kepler noticed that you have to use ellipses to make this really work and then we get a high accuracy.
The lesson to be learned from that is you may want to replace a sophisticated model
with accurate predictions by a far simpler model, less accurate predictions,
just for the sake of understanding.
This is Occam's Razor in action, trying to find the most simple explanation that does the job.